here are 20 quick tips to help you win
terraforming masks if you want to
there's a much longer version of this on
my channel believe it or not this is
actually the short version tip number
one realize that this is an engine
building game and play accordingly so
this means engine first VP later so
generally speaking there are two ways of
doing this you can go for money income
which is micro credit Productions deal
production titanium production also a
little bit of TR something like this so
this is the approach for long games but
if it's in your best interest to close
the game as soon as possible you can
also build your engine with primarily
heat production and terraform rating we
could say that the top half of the
screen here is like the greedy engine
which tends to be better for long games
and then you could argue that the bottom
half of the screen is like the timber
engine better for short games better for
the terraformers and I really want to
make clear here that this is like
extremely oversimplified like even if
you're going for the tempo engine you'll
probably still play a quiet combination
still play titanium mind you'll probably
even still play business Empires or the
mines something like this and likewise
even if you are playing the greedy
engine you can still play some of the
stuff in the bottom of the screen other
examples of tempo engine cards could be
nitrogen-rich asteroid I could be towing
a comet towing a comet is actually kind
of cool because what you do is you wait
until you have exactly four plans and
then you make them water on top of two
plants because then you have a total of
eight plants and then as your second
action you'll build Greenery immediately
and of course if you are going for the
timber engine if you are going for TR to
some extent then of course stuff like
Solitaire and Mojo area these are very
good cards in this case regardless of
what you might have heard me say in the
past then it's also great to get some
card though I think these three cards
here they're really good I would almost
always keep these three but getting back
to card draw in general I think capro
attempts to be better in Long games in
terms of generations which means the
card draw in general is a little bit
better in two or three player games hard
Pro is to some extent part of the greedy
card strategy it is like by the very
nature a bit greedy and completely ruins
your Tempo so Tempo is very important
when you're going for terraforming so
the point I'm trying to make is if
you're rushing then card draw is a
little bit risky to pick up because then
Tempo might be more important for you
than the card draw a random card is
worth around 3 million is a random card
and a two-player game specifically is
worth around 4 Mega credits and the
reason for this is that in these long
greedy two player games the primary
strategy is the grid card strategy if
you're going for the greater game then
the best approach is to get both money
income and capital if you can get a
balance of birth then you can go truly
guard mode and even though I say money
income and capital that's really good
actually Card discount Plus Card Draw
that's even better this can get truly
out of control a TI is worth like
exactly the same as one VP plus one Mega
credit production this is useful
information because this will help you
to evaluate cards so now we know that
nuclear zone for instance well that's
exactly the same as two make a credit
production and a placement bonus which
is actually not too bad for building an
engine as a rule of thumb one terraform
rating is worth 8 Mega credits unless
you want to close the game really badly
in that case you could make the argument
that it's like 9 or 10 mega credits or
something but if we really don't care
about this boring aspect of closing the
game early then I think one terraform
rating is worth eight this is true for
the first generation and it's true for
the last generation here is a graph of
what I think everything is worth
depending on which generation we are
talking about and I've come to realize
that this graph here is mostly
reflecting the greedy approach to
terraforming Mass but if you are playing
a temper engine or maybe just for the
average player in general then I think
you could add one to all the VP and all
the terraform rating in this graph and
also you could lower the mega credit
production just a little bit but you
know what these values here are much
easier to remember these are probably
the values to live by so in the first
generation one terraform rating is
around 8 1vp is around three and one
Mega credit production is around 5
unless you predict it's going to be a
super fast game in that case I would
argue that a mega credit production is
worth around four then in the last
iteration one terraform rating is still
eight and then one VP is also eight and
then Mega credit production is useless
in the last generation tip number two in
the early game you need to focus on
climbing out of their hole first of all
you do this by getting a little bit of
money income you can also get a little
bit of tier for the purposes of engine
building one TR is also kind of worth
one Mega credit production I think it's
always a good idea to get plus 10 money
income as soon as possible in Long games
you need even more because then you need
a huge engine and in short games and
really fast games you could make the
argument that you can make deal with a
little messenger the point is the game
is really hard to play if you don't have
any engine at all if you aim to close
the game super early you can also build
your engine with TR and Heap production
five player game specifically might be
really short in terms of generations so
in these games you might even consider
VP and especially Tia as soon as maybe
the first generation tip number 2.5
engine building cards should be able to
pay for themselves in five or fewer
Generations now we also come back to
this idea that the value of Mega credit
production depends on how long the game
is going to last in terms of generations
so if you're predict the game is going
to be super fast and mega credit
production is worth a little bit less
and finally you should keep in mind that
this rules about five or fewer
Generations this only applies to the
first generation the further we get into
the game the faster card must be able to
pay for itself if you do not climb out
of the hole then the hole might become a
black hole
tip number three in the mid to late game
make the transition from engine to VP
grabbing this is equally as important as
engine building is so I kind of want to
start grabbing VP when there are around
four generations left and pure Victory
Point cards should be played in the last
generation tip number four play to grab
the bonuses under Global parameters so
these are the bonuses that I'm talking
about so what can you actually do to get
these bonuses first of all you can just
keep the right card so I'm talking about
cards that just like LeapFrogs you like
two or three steps off of a global
parameter so for instance we got demos
down or we got giant solar shade or it
could be strip mine secondly do not give
your opponents an easy way to claim the
bonus if you just leave the bonus there
with like one or two steps until the
bonus then there's a pretty high
likelihood that someone else would claim
the bonus before you and thirdly you
want to plan your actions carefully when
you're getting close to a bonus and
finally if you are the first player in
the upcoming generation you can actually
set yourself up to claim the bonus in
the start of the Next Generation and the
reason for this is that if you end this
generation and also start the upcoming
Generations you will have a lot of
actions in a row and you can really use
this to get the bonuses amongst other
things tip number five if you want to
prioritize milestones and show the games
for 5 player games in Long games they
are less important two or three player
games and just to get the awards out of
the way the first award you should claim
like sort of in the early to mid game
but I want to stress this only if you're
really sure you're gonna win it
otherwise it's not worth it I mean it's
only eight Mega credits so if you're
really sure you'll get at the very least
the second place okay maybe it's worth
it but as a general rule you really
don't want to start on a war unless
you're very confident you're gonna win
it the second award that costs 14 you
kind of want to start this in the mid
game and the last award that costs 20
this one is not that important I'm okay
with starting using the late game or
maybe in the very last generation
something like this but getting back to
the Milestones here are the Milestones
that I'm talking about during the early
game you always want to have milestones
in mind and you should always aim to get
one of the milestones at least but I
think there is a little bit of wiggle
room here regarding when to actually
pick up the Milestones though in a
two-player game you want to fight for
the Milestones around generation 5 in a
three player game you want to fight for
the Milestones around Generation 4 in a
four player game you want to fight for
the milestone around renovation 3 and
finally in the five player games you
want to fight for the Milestones as soon
as possible in a five play game it is
actually a Race So the basic idea here
is that in five player games the scores
are much lower because there are fewer
Generations which also means that the
Milestones are just that much more
important because it's like a bigger
part of your score if that makes sense
on the other hand in two player games
the scores are going to be a lot bigger
which means that in two player games the
Milestones are not that important I mean
it's still nice if you can get them but
you don't really have to rush to get all
of them tip number 5.5 don't make too
many bad plays just so you can get a
milestone instead rather go for the
Milestones that Naturally Fit your game
so if you're fastest naturally you'll
gravitate toward the mere milestones and
maybe even the Gardner Milestone and if
you're terraforming like crazy maybe you
um near something then naturally you go
for the terraformer Milestone and to be
honest that's probably the only
Milestone you're gonna get this game but
that's fine tip number six don't buy
Milestone before an opponent is exactly
three actions away from buying it or
technically maybe three accidents away
from claiming their last available spot
if you can wait before claiming a
milestone then you should wait and the
reason for this is that Mega Credit in
the early game is worth a lot more than
Mega credits later on in the game so for
instance the eight Mega credits you
spend on a milestone in the early game
this is actually a huge chunk of your
economy this could have gone into like
engine building or something else like
in one of the games on my channel I
played against the thousands player who
just built three cities immediately
through his Corporation and preludes and
then immediately he just got the mega
Milestone and I was like ah I like the
three cities it's not great but it's not
bad it's okay but when you get the mayor
Milestone immediately that's so
unnecessary you can wait like civil
generation before you have to pick up
this Milestone tip number seven you
should play another generation you
should do the math you don't really have
to but it definitely helps for instance
if you have a really expensive card you
want to play in the Next Generation
because you cannot afford it right now
then you should really do the math
because then you know how much Mega
credits you can actually afford to spend
in this generation so some example of
this really expensive costume might want
to save up for could be Earth elevator
it could be giant solar shade or it
could be Iron Manning Industries so here
are a few examples of math that I do in
most of my games so the first one is all
about what do I want to play in this
upcoming generation so I take my current
Mega credits plus my mega credit
production minus whatever Mega credit I
plan on spending in the Next Generation
also still entertainment stuff is
implied in this case and all of this
should add up to at least zero but
ideally it should be 9 or 12 and the
whole reason for this is that this is
all about how many cards can actually
afford to buy in the research phase so
if it adds up to nine if it adds up to
six then I know I have to restrict
myself to only buying two or three cards
the second piece of math I do is just to
calculate how many generations before a
card will pay for itself and then you
really have to take into account like I
mentioned how many generations do I
think is left in the game and the delay
game is simply calculate which of my
available plays will give the most VP is
a better to play the cards on my hand or
is it better just to start spamming
cities and greeneries so do you need to
do all of this math no does it help to
do all of this math yeah tip number
eight should I aim for a really long
game or should I aim for a short tier
heavy game so let's look at how long a
game of terraforming Mars is actually
going to last in terms of generations so
if you're playing with preludes which
you should preludes is amazing the two
player games will last mostly around 9
to 12 Generations whereas 5 player games
will last mostly 6 to 9 Generations so
these are the average number of
generations across all players but it
really depends on the meta because
players who enjoys having fun with their
greedy engine hello they will likely
have longer games so for people like me
who enjoys the greedy games it's not
unheard of that the games goes to 11 or
12 or 13 generations and then you might
be thinking well well the other guy can
just close it but the two player games
is not that easy but this is a little
bit of a self-fulfilling prophecy right
because I enjoy 3D games so most of my
games are gonna be greedy especially two
player games but then if another guy
enjoys like going really like super fast
games then most of these games is going
to be super fast right and speaking of
those guys I should mention that the top
ranked players will have super fast
games it comes down to that they are
more efficient in just getting
everything done a little bit sooner and
also it's just the matter right The Meta
in these top 100 ranked games is just
that the game ends at bit sooner and
then we're kind of back to the
self-fulfilling prophecy that if the
meta in these high games are just super
fast then the best strategy is to be
super fast tip number 8.5 in two or
three player games aim to play the
greedy card strategy every single game
this comes down to the fact that two or
three player games tends to be longer in
terms of generations which means you can
get away with more greed but I thought
about this some more and I realized that
this also kind of depends on the meta it
depends on how fast your opponents wants
to close the game so after taking this
into consideration I think this is a
more accurate way to look at it in games
that last 10 plus generation you should
aim to play the greedy card strategy
every single time so in 10th Generation
I think it's a little bit of a draw I
think the greedy car strategy could win
and also the terraformer could win but
if you go to generation 11 or more I
think the greedy cast reality has a
higher likelihood of winning and then
you might be thinking well when I start
a game I don't really know how many
generations the game is going to last
and while this is true there's still a
bunch of things you can do to actually
try to identify this first of all number
of players is good indication the fewer
number of players you are the long
longer the game is going to last in
terms of generations secondly you can
try to take into account The Meta like
the opponent you're playing against
these guys do they enjoy long games or
do they enjoy short TR heavy games and
thirdly around generation 2 or 3 you
should have a pretty good idea if you
look at enemy plan product in an enemy
here production especially you should
have a pretty good idea of what they are
trying to do and how many generations
the game is going to last the greedy
cops reality can also work in four to
five play games but it is a lot more
risky in four to five play games the
terraformers or you could also say the
tempo engines these type of guys have a
higher likelihood of beating you just
because of the fact that the game tends
to be shorter in terms of generations
having all of this in the back of your
head is very useful But ultimately what
it comes down to is you have to play
with the cards again tip number nine get
heat production in the early to mid game
or if you are a really greedy guy like
me who enjoys long games then maybe just
never get it at all the point is heat
production is not that efficient when it
comes to building your engine and plan
production is actually even worse I'll
get back to that but of course if you
are going for the tempo engine if you
want to close the game Super fast then
of course go for it here production is
good in that case so what is a heat
production actually worth and the other
game is worth around 5 Mega credits
which is the same as a mega credit
production also around 5 Mega credits
but if you're going for the really fast
game if it's in your best interest to
close the game as soon as possible then
of course you could argue that it's
worth a little bit more than five Mega
credits I think I nailed the main
difference between heat production and
plan production so playing production is
always good regardless of your strategy
heat production is always fine but it's
kinda a lot better if you're going for
the TR strategy if you want to close the
game control the game and since this is
a logic we're using we could also flip
the coin and say if you're the greedy
guy you got the big engine you want the
game to drag out for as long as possible
in that case you should only get hit
production if it's a really good deal if
you get some discount or something or
maybe you already can see that heat is
not the last parameter to close in that
case heat production is still fine when
his heat production actually good one
you played early initially my thought
about hit production is that it is
better if you want to close the game but
then I spoke to this formal rank one
player on Steam and he actually said
that it is also good if you want to
control the game and when he's talking
about controlling the game what he means
is that it actually has some value just
to have the opportunity to be able to
close the game faster depending how it
all goes and while it's not always the
temperature that's the last parameter to
close it is kind of true that the amount
of heat production around the table
actually kind of dictates how long the
game is going to go so if you want to be
one of the guys who has a little more
influence in which generation the game
is gonna close then heat production is
good but you could argue this is a minor
thing to be honest mainly what you want
to remember is that if you are trying to
close the game then heat production is
good and finally if you're getting a
really good deal in here production
maybe you have some discount or you
could have a heat combo so the point
here is that heat production is a lot
worse once the parameters Max which is
why it's really good to have stuff like
melt Works helium cats like a contract
insulation and this is of course
assuming that heat production is not the
last parameter to close because if it is
the last parameter to close then you're
fine either way then also put in optimal
error braking in Media Group and I just
feel like these cards are often very
good with this GP production space event
cards step number 10 and get plane
production in the mid game or at the
very least after you've built an engine
of some kind land production is always
good like no matter what strategy you're
going for however it's a very bad way of
building your engine which is why I
think the sweet spot for win to get
plane production is exactly in the mid
game because if you think about it one
Greenery is kind of worth like three
victory points one Victory point for the
greenery one tier for the oxygen and one
VP next to your city it could be a
little bit more it could be a little bit
less but the point here is there's not a
lot of engine building here is there
it's only like one TR for the oxygen
that's the only engine building you're
getting out of this the thing to keep in
mind is that plants and greeneries are
mainly a way to get victory points in
fact I would go so far as to say that
having one or two plant production in
the early game is just straight up there
unless of course maybe you have a plan
to actually convert your plans into
Greenery in this generation or the Next
Generation maybe you're intending to get
claims off of placement bonuses or
something so you can convert pretty
soonish in that case you can be excused
but generally speaking having one or two
playing production in the early game is
bad it and here is why so the first
reason is that this is money you could
have spent an engine instead and also
early plane Productions tends to be
really expensive it's a lot cheaper
later on once the requirements gets made
but in the early game it's very
expensive secondly if you only have one
or two plan production then it will take
you like four generations just to get
one Greenery down and even that one
Greener is only gonna be worth one money
income and the third reason is this guy
if it's actually that many generations
just to get one Greenery down then
chances are someone will have burned
your plans before you get to that point
here are some planned amplifiers you
could be considering except for maybe
worms all of these are great cards and
if you are going for plane production it
could also make sense that you're going
for Green Tech Synergy Green Tech
Synergy can actually give you a lot of
points especially if you're going for
the long game a card like meat
Industries can get completely out of
control if you're going for animals so
you could make the argument that plant
production goes hand in hand with green
text Synergy but then again you could
also make the argument that plant
production goes hand in hand with this
city strategy so generally speaking plan
production is better to play in the mid
game but naturally if you get some of
these insane late game plan production
cards of course you also play some of
these and in the last generation all of
a sudden Clan production is good again
because in the last generation is all
about getting eight plants so you can
make a Greenery in the extra round so in
the last generation you kind of want to
play to make your plans plus plan
production equal to 8 or 16 plants or
maybe a little bit more than this and
the reason is this guy so maybe this guy
hasn't had the time to play Birds
earlier maybe just picked it up or maybe
it just deliberately kept it in his hand
just to grieve you in the last
generation just to make sure that you
cannot build an extra Greenery in the
extra round and this can of course be
really annoying which is why it could be
a good idea to keep just a little bit of
extra plants just in case but actually
the biggest thing you could do to
counter this is to slow play in the last
generation we'll talk more about this in
tip number 14 but basically the point is
that if you pass the generation and he
plays Birds there's nothing you can do
but if he plays birds and you still have
a few actions left maybe there's
something you could do to actually
counter this maybe you can get a
placement bonus or maybe you have a card
with a few plans on it or something tip
number 11 buy colonies is especially
Luna and Pluto even if it is with the
standard project for 17 you know what
the standard product is actually often
good enough in the early game and of
course if you get some of these Colony
cards that would be even more inclined
to go for colonies these caps are good I
would be happy to see most of these
cards in my opening hand here are the
colonies in the early game you're
probably looking for some income it
could be Ceres or luna Pluto is also
really good if you're going for The
Temper engine stuff like IO and gaining
beat are of course also good choices and
in the mid to late game if you just want
to get a bunch of points you go for
interletters Titan and especially
Miranda to be honest all of these
colonies are actually really good it
just depends on the situation as it is
with all cap raw Pluto is a little bit
better if you have an engine to support
it like if you have no engine at all
it's actually a little hard to justify
spending 17 just to get Pluto to get
some cards but if you do have a lot of
money income then Pluto is straight up
the best colony and in the first
generation if you do have the choice
between playing a colony and Luna for 17
or playing some some optimal card of
some sort and of course I would prefer
Luna every single time imagine if you
will in your opening hand you have a
card that you played three to buy so it
costs 14 and gives you three Mega credit
production maybe a little bit more than
three Mega credit production that's
pretty good that's basically Luna but
once again it must be said that make a
credit production in general is better
if you expect the game to go long but if
you expect the game to be over in six
Generations then Luna is maybe not worth
it also of course it depends on what
other cards you have in your opening
hand maybe you have something better tip
number 11.5 in most cases you want to
buy a colony as your first action and
then trade there immediately as your
second action the only scenario I can
think of where you buy a colony and
don't trade there immediately it must be
because that you're anticipating someone
else to trade there right now or maybe
you just desperately want the last
available spot on that Colony tip number
12 if you are playing with colonies you
want to get three energy production as
soon as possible it's a little hard to
explain but it is somehow just a lot
cheaper to trade with three energy
compared to three Titanium or nine Mega
credits here are some different ways you
can get energy production in the early
game you kind of don't want to buy too
many of these power plants for 11 but
you know if you have two energy
production and you can get the third by
buying a power plant go for it tip
number 13 some things are better to do
at the start of a generation and some
things are better to do at the end of a
generation so here are some examples of
stuff you want to do as soon as possible
in a generation so this could be
Milestone or Awards it could be getting
the last few available Tia if the
parameter is about to close it could be
getting the best placement bonuses on
the map it could be claiming a bonus
also on the global parameters it could
be spending your plans before you
actually get hit by a comment so once
again that's because of this guy could
also be Attack cards and it could also
be a fake cast that gives you X when
opponents does y so I'm talking about
pits I'm talking about immigrant City
stuff like this here's some stuff you
want to do as late as possible in a
generation so for instance you want to
play cards and use actions where you get
X based on opponents y so that's not the
same as I just mentioned because what we
mentioned before was effects this is
basically the wrist now I'm talking tall
station I'm talking Galilean weigh
station I'm talking Martian rails so
these are the type of cards that benefit
from you waiting for as long as possible
before playing it so for instance
greenhouses why would you play this at
the start of the generation maybe during
the generation someone will build a city
so you play this as late as possible and
obviously when we're talking greenhouses
and Martian rails and stuff like this
it's not actually the last thing you do
in a generation it's like the second to
last thing you do in a generation
because the last thing should be to spin
the plants or spend the mega credits you
get from actually using these cards
other things you want to do as late as
possible in a generation for example you
want to make plays to set yourself up to
win a race at the beginning at the
upcoming generation you want to
terraform with action cards and heat
resources also as late as possible you
want to decrease enemy energy production
if they're using it to trade a power and
action card or something like this so
basically if an opponent has exactly one
energy production you probably want to
steal that as soon as possible but if he
has three and he's using these three
energy production to trade if he's
played an action card or something that
uses energy and you can see well it's
exactly the energy he needs to use this
action card in the Next Generation then
you actually want to steal it as late as
possible because this way you could do
the most damage because then he's got to
pass the generation and then you see
and then there's nothing he can do about
it and also if an opponent has Predators
you want to make animals as late as
possible in the generation or maybe not
at all it kind of depends right it could
be that someone else around the table
also has an animal card and maybe the
Predator will then steal from that guy
instead of you because maybe you have
zero animals on your car this doesn't
happen very often but it's just a thing
to keep in mind tip number 14 you want
to spend only one action on your turn
unless you have a reason to actually
spend two actions why is it better to
generally only spend one action on your
turn first of all your opponents kind of
show their hand before you do and it
also gives you essentially more actions
in a row so why is it better to have
many actions in a row for example you
can surprise claim a milestone you can
claim the bonuses without being
contested on the global parameters and
it's more like things under your control
if that makes sense that's just a lot of
scenarios that will benefit you if you
do not show your hand before your
opponents and there are a bunch of
exceptions to this rule it's a could be
for instance that the players around the
table maybe just prefer that you take
two actions on your turn maybe you're
playing casually or something like this
some groups prefer it like this it could
be that there's some lot of race going
on so maybe if you're like close to
getting a milestone oh the other guy is
also close to getting a milestone I just
have to beat that guy to get the
Milestone something like this could also
be setting yourself up to get a better
placement bonus on the map so for
example if you play a city and then
immediately you want to play Greenery
next to the city and maybe also next to
water or something also in most cases if
you're building a colony You Want To
Build The Colony as the first action and
then trade immediately as the second
action also if you have exactly zero
energy production it's a good idea to
play around energy tapping and power
supply Consortium so you do this by
actually making the energy as your first
action and then you spend energy
immediately Associate Connection could
also be that you acquire plans as your
first action and then you build a
Greenery immediately as a second action
so this is how you play around asteroids
could also be that you just have one
thing you want to do this generation and
then you just spend all your mega
credits titanium and steel immediately
because this way you play around
sabotage air raid and hired Raiders well
it's basically only if you have one big
expensive cars like Iron Man Industries
or something tip number 14.5 in the last
generation it is especially important to
only you take one action on your turn so
why is this a little bit extra important
in the last generation first of all what
if it's not the last generation it could
be the case that your opponents are
surprised closing the game but it could
also be the case that he's surprised not
closing the game which can be equally
devastating slow playing is also crucial
for fighting for balls so for example do
I have a make a credit production card
in my hand maybe I want to keep that for
as long as possible because maybe
someone is gonna contest me in the
banker or something it was kind of nice
to know do I have to actually play this
useless card in the last generation that
does nothing for me except giving me a
mega credit production or can I afford
selling this and spend my mega credits
on something better or something that
gives me a point for example could also
be that someone started the miner and
you're actually winning the miner but
you're only winning it if you're not
spending your resources in that case is
also really beneficial for you if the
other guy actually passes before you
because then you know exactly how much
steel and titanium you can actually
spend on your Jovian amplifiers or
something like this while still winning
the miner also if you pass the last
generation before your opponent they
might remove your plan slash plan
production preventing you from making
that plus one Greenery so we're back to
this guy this is really annoying if you
pass before your opponent then you're
more vulnerable to card like birds or
something like this and if you yourself
is actually the bird person then it's
the same deal right you want to wait for
as long as possible before removing
enemy plants or plant production because
if the opponent has passed then you can
actually just count how many plants you
can make the extra round and you can
know if you'll actually grieve him by
playing birds secondly if we already
passed the generation well then there's
nothing he could do about it so
basically in the last generation it's an
advantage if you are the last guy to
pass the last generation so basically
what I'm saying is you shall not pass
the last generation before your
opponents if possible so keeping this in
mind you could also say that there's a
little bit of an advantage to actually
have a lot of action cards and stuff
like this because it'll give you a small
Advance into the last iteration could
also be that the temperature parameters
Max and you still have a bunch of heat
left over well you can actually just
slow play by making eight heat into
absolutely nothing and then pass the
turn it's a little bit frowned upon to
be honest you have to be some sort of
artist to actually do this but it's
something you can do so when it's better
to actually take two actions on turn in
the last generation generally this is
only something you do right at the start
of the last generation if you want to do
it so maybe you're in a rush to start
the last award maybe you're in a rush to
get the last few available Tia before
the parameter closes completely or maybe
you want one of the good placement
bonuses on the map or just any placement
bonuses all maybe the map is filling up
completely tip number 15 card sequence
do not play a card until you need it for
something so generally speaking in your
build accounts should be played in the
early to mid game and pure VP cards
should be played in the last generation
so why is it that some cards are better
if you play them later on first of all
Mega credits is worth more in the early
game compared to the late game so this
is why you don't want to play a pure VP
card in the first generation it does
nothing for you it doesn't build your
engine in any way and also during the
game perhaps the cards become cheaper
because you pick up discount cards so
these are the discard cards I'm talking
about so why would you play some card
that does nothing for you except give
you VP in the early game when you could
just wait for the entire game and then
you pick up some discount on that you
could play for Chiba in the last
generation also some cards are simply
worth more if you played on later I'll
get back to that in the next tip and
finally you kind of don't want to show
your hand until you absolutely have to
so for example Jovian amplifiers you
kind of don't want to play these cards
until the last generation except for
iron mining Industries so this is
basically because it's only VP but it's
also because then you're giving away the
fact that you are indeed going for
jovians this game so if you're going for
Drafting and people already know that
you're going for jovians because you
maybe you played water import from a
Europe or something well then they're
not gonna pass you so many jovians in
the drafting phase right could also be
videos in animals so if you're playing
this card too early then you're kind of
giving away the fact that you're going
for science this game and then people
are less likely to pass your science
tags in the drafting phase so you really
don't want to play a card until you have
a reason to do so so you want to play
colonizer training camp as late as
possible but still within the five
oxygen requirements so this could be
when the oxygen is like three to five or
something don't play ecological zone or
decomposers until you plan on playing a
green tag next don't play herbivores
until you plan on placing greeneries and
once again don't play the news in
animals until you plan on playing a
science tag next so basically what I'm
saying is you must have a clear reason
to play the card that you're about to
play if the reason is nothing except for
VP then you should play it in the last
generation tip number 16 some cards are
potentially worth more when played later
on the biggest examples that comes to
mind are science tags and green tags so
for example I forgot to research this
gives you like two cards and one Victory
point just this card alone but then if
you also have Olympus conference Mars
University and venusian animals then all
of a sudden research just this card
gives you three card a rotation of two
cards and three victory points another
example is Advanced ecosystem by itself
this card just gives you 3 VP but if you
don't play it until the last generation
and then during the game you picked up
while enhancers decomposes ecological
Zone then all of a sudden this card
alone is worth three plans and five
victory points so in 99 out of 100 cases
you wanna play Advanced ecosystems in
the last generation and also there are a
few cards here that just gets better the
later in the game you actually play them
but generally speaking you also want to
play these as late as possible but it's
not quite like this because sometimes
you just need the plan so the mega
credit is right here right now to make
an amazing play and then of course you
want to play these a bit soon in that
case and tip number 17 you want to play
to maximize resource amplifiers they can
be really good sometimes they're just
straight up when you're the game but of
course by Nature these are very
situational so what you do is you pick
up a resource amplifiers like one of
these cards and then you try to figure
out can I make this work in my game does
it align with the plan I have so most of
the time these just give you like
average value you play it and you're
like all right that's fine some of the
time they're completely useless maybe
you don't have one Earth tag in this
game why would you pick up cartel and
sometimes they're just straight up when
you're the game sometimes you get 10
mega credit production from playing
satellite or if it's a four or five
player game especially tall station is
insane something like this so when you
see these cards you just have to make an
assessment is this the perfect card for
this game that I'm playing right now
like if you have a bunch of green tags
and you just Chopstick insects it can be
incredibly powerful so just keep your
eye out for these cars and naturally if
you have stuff like insects cartel
satellites you should maximize the value
of these cards by playing as many tags
as possible before you're playing these
cards but also keep in mind the
production is better the earlier you get
it really depends on how many
generations the game is going to last
and stuff like this tip number 18 you
want to play the Good cards taken into
account the number of players in the
game because some cars are really good
in two player games and other cards are
really good in five player games so for
example Attack cards the cap with the
red border I would argue that these are
slightly better in two player games why
because then you're damaging a hundred
percent of your opponents and also if
someone retaliates well you're only two
player so he's only gonna retaliate and
you also the really greedy cards they
tend to be better in two-player games as
well so for example we got AI Central
anti-gravity technology and
interplanetary trade these cards can be
very powerful but it does take a lot of
time to set this up so what I mean is if
you play this in a five player game
maybe the game is just gonna be over
before you actually benefit from these
cards so this is why generally speaking
these cars tend to be a bit stronger in
two or three player games simply because
there's gonna be more Generations just
because you're only two players and then
you can get the conditions where these
cards can really shine because you want
to benefit from having these cars for
like a lot of generations so definitely
these cards are just better on longer
games which is why they're better in two
player games and also for the same
reason in these long drawn out
two-player games the card draw cards are
just really good as well because the
go-to strategy in two player games is
the card strategy and it makes sense the
more Generations you have the more cards
you can draw and especially the more of
these new character can actually get to
play in these long games so let's go in
the other direction and talk about five
player games so I think these cards here
are a little bit better in five play
games so we're talking fastest Posada
and Tall station Quantum communication
Catalan way station is worth noting that
a corporation like Poseidon is still
good in two player game is just a solid
cooperation but it is a little bit
better than five player games so to a
lesser extent I will also argue that CDC
energetic cards are also generally a
little bit better in four or five player
games but this one is not as clear
because in some two-player games there
are more cities being played than 5 play
games but statistically speaking these
cards are just a little bit better than
five player games and the four five
player games people also tend to favor
Tia a little bit more and it makes sense
because in five play games it's gonna be
very short so you want some engine you
want some VP as soon as possible and tia
just you both tip number 19 don't be
afraid to use stand-up projects but use
them wisely so first of all standard
technology makes all the standard
projects better especially the colony
standard project in the early game but
that being said let's assume we don't
have standard technology so generally
the way the game works is that the card
is always more efficient than the
standard projects but sometimes you
don't have the right card for the
situation so let's go through them real
quickly so we got cell patterns well
generally you should sell when necessary
even if it is a card you paid three Mega
credit for but the thing is you kind of
don't want to sell your cards until you
need that plus one Mega credits because
your cards could end up being worthwhile
because maybe the bad card on your hand
just have the tag you need all of a
sudden or maybe you get some discount to
make the cap worth it could also be the
case that you just need bad cards in
your hand to cycle it could be because
of Master University sponsored academies
a Pluto and then we got the power plant
well if you need it you need it it is a
bit expensive to pay 11 Mega credits
just to get one energy production but it
could be the case to just have a card or
you want to set yourself up to trade or
something so in a lot of cases you
actually do Buy by this and then we've
got asteroid and Ash grabbing and these
two standard projects are generally the
worst in the game so basically you'll
never want to play asteroid unless well
maybe you can get the water placement
bonus on the temperature scale in that
case is really good to get it could also
be that you just need to close the game
and this is actually the biggest one
especially if you are the terraformer if
it benefits you in some way to close the
game as soon as possible there will
actually arise a bunch of scenarios
where you just build a bunch of
asteroids especially in the last
generation maybe the last two
generations and finally it could also be
that you're close to playing a good card
with temperature requirement but it has
to be one of the really good cars they
basically have to be farming trees or
fish the ash grabbing standard project
where you pay 15 to get one Venus this
is really hard to find the redeeming
factor for this one this one's just
straight up bad the only example I can
think of where I would consider getting
this is because you want to play the new
scene animals or maybe you can grab the
bonus on the Venus scale and then we got
the aquifier standard project for 18.
once again this is also pretty terrible
if you actually do the math but there
are actually some redeeming factors here
they got quite
you do want to play this sometimes so
first of all it could be the case that
you're close to playing a good card with
ocean requirements so it could be killed
farming Penguins it pretty much has to
be one of these two cars to be worth it
to be honest could also be capital and
stuff like this could be that you have
some water Synergy going on could also
be once again you just desperately need
to close the game as soon as possible or
it could also be that you can get one of
the really good placement bonuses the
thing is you have two actions on your
turn so if you can place a water at your
first action and then you play something
amazing next to the water as your second
action it can actually be quite good
then we got the city and the greenery
standard projects and the main thing to
understand about these is that this is
pretty much a way to get victory points
it's not good in the early game if you
want to build your engine with cities
then you pretty much have to have
immigrant City Marching real fastest
maybe two out of these three cards
otherwise the city standard project is
straight up banned in the early game
it's much better if you have a card with
a city that's much better greeneries is
pretty much the same deal it's very bad
for building your engine especially if
we're talking the standard project build
a Greenery for 23 Mega credits but in
the late game it's very common to
actually buy a bunch of these standard
Greenery project for 23 and the reason
is is a pretty good way to get victory
points in the late game so when should
you actually buy cities and greeneries
well maybe you need to close the game
maybe you want the last few available TR
before the parameter is about to close
maybe you can get the temperature bonus
on the oxygen scale or maybe you're
close to playing a good card with oxygen
requirement but pretty much what this
all comes down to is that in the late
game you kind of want to build cities
and greeneries to actually get VP and
finally we got the colony standard
project as I mentioned I think this
standard product is actually really good
it's definitely the best standard
project in the early game and in the
late game you could argue that citizen
greeneries is better but no matter how
you slice it you should always look for
the colonies is it actually better to
just straight up buy a colony rather
than playing the card in my hand
sometimes it is and finally tip number
20 don't keep casting your opening hand
that has a crazy requirement unless so
this one is a little bit of a gray area
so in my opening hand I would never keep
any of this stuff it's way too late game
so the only exception would be if I have
the ecology experts Prelude then of
course trees is really good so in the
early game pretty much only keep mid to
lift game that's if your economy is
strong enough to pay the three Mega
credit for a car that you are not soon
to use and secondly the card must
benefit you a lot when you then finally
do play it because what you have to keep
in mind is the three Mega credits in the
early game it could be worth more like
10 mega credits than they get so you
just have to make sure that the cards
you keep in the early game is worth the
high price of keeping it so you could
say a good tip for beginners is to not
keep a card that you are not going to
use here and now but it doesn't really
reflect the whole truth the truth is a
lot of good players actually do tend to
keep a lot of mid to late game cards
pretty early on actually so examples of
late game cards you might want to keep
could be the Joven amplifiers it could
be some other really good juicy science
tags it could also be some of the plan
production cars especially the plant
amplifiers could also be the green tag
amplifiers if I'm going for green tags I
actually tend to keep these cards pretty
early on as well these can be very
powerful so it comes down to two things
basically first of all is your engine
actually strong enough to keep these
late game cards in the early game and
secondly it's a lot about Tempo because
terraforming mass is a snowballing game
so if you're keeping a lot of late game
cards in your hand then you're kind of
delaying the the snowball a little bit
so you could actually make the argument
that if you're playing all in on the
terraform rating or linen cities then
Tempo is actually pretty important for
use in that case you cannot really
afford to keep so many late game cards
so that's really what I mean when I talk
about Tempo but on the other hand if we
had a two-player game it's a really long
game maybe 13 Generations then you
definitely want to keep a lot of late
game cards but that's pretty much it
here the first 10 tips if you want to
pause the video here are the tips from
11 to 20 and in case you want to dive
just a little bit deeper into
educational terraforming mask videos I
have these 20 episodes planned on my
channel most of these should be on my
channel already thanks for watching